don't spend money till you're making
money teach yourself that at the
beginning of your Venture you are not
going to spend your money until you're
actually making money what are you going
to do you invest your heart your hustle
your energy your drive your motivation
but you're not investing your money
until you're making money people say
well don't you need money to make money
like you don't need money to make money
you need your energy you need your
resourcefulness as soon as you focus on
resources as being the problem you've
lost and it's never a lack of resources
it's a lack of resourcefulness it's you
feeling that it's a lack of resources
that is the problem and that prevents
action that prevents Forward Motion
because if you hey if I only had x
amount of money then I would be able to
do this there's always a way to start
smaller there's always a smaller way to
get started and to teach yourself
especially at the beginning that you
want to be more resourceful that you
don't want to spend your money until
you're making money so instead of
focusing on how you can spend money that
you don't have think about how can you
do something with what you do have and
to invest your heart your energy your
time your hustle your drive but not your
money until you're making money step one
is you dream big but you act small the
big mission you've got is amazing that's
what's going to fuel you you don't want
to feel like every day you're waking up
and doing something small you've got
this big drive this big ambition it's
awesome and act small today do something
instead of waiting for venture capital
or somebody put you on or to co-sign you
just do something dream big act small
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because chances
are you are the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Evan Carmichael and our take on his top
10 rules for Success enjoy
[Music]
rule number two take control of your
thoughts most of us never take control
of our self-talk you you don't take
control of the thoughts that you have
about yourself when you're by yourself
it doesn't even matter as much what our
parents think what our friends think
what our husband our wife thinks it's
you you're the problem you think
negatively about yourself you are not
consistently feeling yourself with
thoughts with positivity with ambition
with Courage the default pattern is one
of mediocrity of one of I can't do this
one of lack of resourcefulness and so
that's what you live and it's possible
to change and in making that shift and
making that change you become an
entirely different person we talk about
how do you become the best version of
yourself how do you live your life how
do you how do you show up as that proud
version this is it it's taking control
of the automatic self-talk that you have
to yourself even if you don't actually
talk to yourself even if you're not
saying Evan you're an idiot right Evan
you can't do that even if you're not
saying those things out loud you're
feeling those things
it's at a subconscious level and this is
where you're playing small and limiting
yourself I
I'm afraid a lot
I'm afraid a lot and I used to let that
fear dominate me I used to let that fear
prevent me from doing the thing that I
needed to do whether it's making videos
whether it's speaking on stage whether
it's interviewing people I don't believe
in being Fearless I think if you're
Fearless it means that you are just
doing the things that are inside your
comfort zone you're photocopying your
life I think if you're Fearless you
actually hate your life because you're
just doing things that you know how to
do I think fear is a great thing
it's not being Fearless it's having the
fear and then showing up because of not
even despite of because of because
you're afraid then you have to go do the
thing because you're worried then you
have to go do the thing because you're
afraid of somebody's judgment and you
have to go do them just because just to
teach yourself that you do it so for me
speaking on stage doing interviews
making videos with a three that I
struggled with the most this is a guy
who's made 10 000 videos has spoken in
front of thousands of people I've done
interviews with some of the biggest
people on the planet I'm still afraid
every time
I'm still afraid every time
and I don't let that fear now stop me
from doing the thing I'm still you know
I had Tony Robbins on my channel uh and
I had him on three years or two years
before
but I'm still nervous to have him on my
heart's still beating like crazy I'm
still an emotional wreck the day of I'm
still not focused
on anything else I can't do any other
work I can't make any other videos
because I'm I'm stressed about the
interview going well I still worry about
these things doesn't go away there's
just levels to this
and I still want to show up where old
Evan younger Evan used to
find a reason why I couldn't do it find
reason why I couldn't show up live in
the fear and justify it as an actual
reason or excuse but deep down I'll
justify think about your reasons like
why can't you do this thing what are you
telling yourself that you can't do
really deep down it's just
a hate
there's no really good reason you've
convinced yourself there's a reason but
deep down you're just afraid right if
you're actually honest with yourself
you're just afraid rule number three
don't live in regret living in regret
sucks
imagine you are 95 years old you're
looking back on your life at this moment
on this day realizing that you could
have played bigger you could have done
more you had more potential you had an
opportunity in front of you you could
have done something and you didn't you
didn't because you were afraid you came
up with some some reason that you
actually believed that was really an
excuse you played small you didn't
accomplish your goals now you're 95
years old and it's over and you can't do
it you're not physically or mentally
able to actually do it
the more you can actually feel that
that today matters that you want to stop
living your life by other people's
opinions and stop living with the fear
of regret
stop having that thing hanging over your
head that you could have done something
and you were too afraid to do it the
more you can actually feel that it can
push you to actually take an action
because otherwise you live the life that
every Everybody lives that most people
live most people regret their life most
people regret not the things that they
did but the things that they didn't do
regret the ideas that you had then you
saw somebody else make a ton of money
off of you regret the conversation that
you wanted to take but you are too
afraid to go introduce yourself like we
live in this
zone of regret already you can feel it
look back to things that happened last
year two years ago or five years ago
like you wish that you showed up a
certain way you wish that you had more
courage more boldness and you didn't do
it you didn't do it and the point isn't
to beat yourself up over that the point
is to use that as courage to go do
something today towards accomplishing
your goals I used to use the fear of
regret a lot when I was when I was
younger especially to get myself to take
action the biggest decision of all the
hardest decision of all was to when I
was 19 not take the 100K a year dream
job that I thought I wanted to go become
an entrepreneur make 300 bucks a month
own 30 of a company that was the hardest
thing ever and the thing that gave me
the courage to do it was the fear of
regret
and Jeff Bezos has a great uh regret
minimization framework he calls it where
basically he tries to project out to
being you know that old old old old old
man and living life with as few regrets
as possible so I asked myself what will
I regret more
well I regret more saying no to my dream
job
and making six figures and travel around
the world or will I regret more saying
no to this business
and just not knowing
and I thought you know what I can always
go get another job
it may not be the same job it may not be
the same company it may not be the same
opportunity it may not be as much money
it may not be as much travel may not be
this perfect job but I could get another
similar job I felt like I could get
another similar job this business idea
this business opportunity I didn't know
that I would ever have this chance again
and so I said you know what even if the
most likely outcome is failure I didn't
think it was going to blow up I didn't
know that it was going to work out or
not even if the most likely scenario is
failure I still have to do it because I
don't want to live with regret and I
told myself I would rather know and fail
than not know rule number four show
empathy the number one way to deal with
negative people in your life is through
empathy it's empathy it's not it's not
hating them back it's not spreading
negativity it's not reminding yourself
that you're better than them it's it's
empathy and it's not even just feeling
bad for them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
I default to assuming that people are
good this is a wild idea people are good
humans are good I've done the who
exercised the year one word exercise
helping people find the most important
core value with so many people and it's
always something positive
I believe that
99.99999999 of people are good there's a
tiny tiny tiny percentage of people who
enjoy killing people and maybe have you
know a few screws loose up here but for
the most part we're good everybody has
dreams everybody has Ambitions everybody
wants to serve everybody wants to be in
a better place than where they are right
now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and and it didn't work out
and because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against him it's that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that and
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you think
about your experiences your life think
about when you've been in a lot of pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe insult somebody did you
maybe say something that you're not
proud of that you later would regret has
it has that ever happened to you so that
you're a bad person it's not that you're
a toxic person it's not that you're a
hater
you were just in a lot of pain
and so the people who are throwing shade
at you are in a lot of pain they're
struggling and just recognizing that
just trying to put yourself in their
shoes and look at their life and if you
know them you can actually look at their
life and if you don't know them you can
assume things about their life if
somebody's coming to leaving a negative
comment on your YouTube video the fact
that that is the highlight of their day
speaks volumes about them right if the
best part of your day is going to
somebody's YouTube channel leaving some
nasty comment that gets you feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in mention what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning the natural
reaction is to be defensive like well no
I'm not this and how could you call me
that
and we want the people around to support
us and cheer us on and tell us that
we're doing the right thing so the
natural
defense mechanism kicks in where we say
no I'm that's not that's not right but
if you take a breather you can take a
step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain what it does is removes
The Sting from the words it removes the
Venom from the words it doesn't get you
to react as emotionally it allows you to
show up more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts from
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're gonna get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start sharing to start releasing to
start living your life the life that you
want not somebody else's version of it
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five
follow the right order there's an order
to things as a sequence to things part
of the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they're just not doing
the things in the right order
you're trying to tackle that big mission
from the start
doing all 30 things at the same time
and not making any money and not making
any momentum not making any progress and
ultimately not having the impact that
you want to have
so out of your 30 ideas all inside your
mission amazing which one is actually
going to start getting you paid
because when you can start making money
everything becomes better everything
becomes easier you can quit your job you
can pay your bills you can hire a team
you can have a bigger impact right if
you had a team of 10 people versus you
doing things part-time on the weekends
and evenings
I'm just gonna have a much bigger impact
if you have you working full time in it
and a team around you how do you get
there what's the one idea out of the 30.
rule number six
catch the pattern catching that pattern
it's like oh it happened again again I
wanted to go and do this and I didn't do
it again I had this opportunity to talk
to somebody and I played small again I
had this chance and I didn't do it and
you're gonna catch it
a day later a couple days later and
reflect back on it and realize okay I
should have done it next time I'm going
to try to have more awareness
step one is just the awareness game
because it's the problem is it's it's so
autopilot we play small by default
especially we've been doing it for
decades you play small by default so
it's so ingrained so natural so
autopilot that we have to slowly shift
out of autopilot Zone eventually what's
gonna happen is you're gonna catch it
in less than a day you're gonna catch it
a couple hours later they're gonna catch
it an hour later they're gonna catch it
10 minutes later they're gonna catch it
five minutes later and then step number
two is you're gonna get to this magical
moment you're gonna get to this magical
moment where it's about to happen you've
caught it you've caught your small
thinking you've caught your scared
thinking you've caught your excuses
thinking
in the actual moment that it's happening
this is a magical spot right now because
you're actually calling yourself out on
your own BS right now and what you need
to do is get enough courage to actually
take the action to Pivot courses to
instead of doing what you historically
normally would do on autopilot now we're
going to take the other action the
action where you're proud of yourself
the action that you don't want to live
and regret
that version of you showing up rule
number seven
spend time with yourself spend a little
time with yourself
and and finish the sentence I am what I
am blank I am blank what's the blank you
are what if you're just by yourself you
have a little space to breathe from your
environment you are what what are some
of the words that come up what are some
of the positive words what are some of
the negative words that show up if
you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hope with some positive ones
so
um for me it could be I'm someone who
believes I am uh I am a great husband
so I'm paying attention I am you know a
great father I am a great not owner what
do you do with dogs I don't know a great
thing still consider your kids they're
my kids yeah doc kids pet kids all right
you know I am a bit down on the negative
side like I am uh afraid of
disappointing people I am scared of
speaking on stages I'm worried that I'm
gonna ask bad interview questions like
what are the positive and negatives if
you fill in the I am okay just to get
awareness of yourself this starts to
uncover some of the subconscious
behavior that you're living on autopilot
right the subconscious is the autopilots
what you're doing by default the
conscious of what we want to take
control of to then turn into
subconscious to then make
the automatic the positive the ambitious
the Bold the courageous right
so start with I am what that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words so what are
the trigger words that you use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing so my three trigger words
are scary difficult or hard that when I
say scary difficult hard
those used to be the reasons why I
couldn't do something those used to be
the reasons why I would let myself off
the hook those used to be the things I
would tell myself oh I can't do this
because it's scary I can't do this
because it's difficult I won't show up
because it's hard
and I would let myself off the hook for
those things that I would say oh that's
okay because it's scary so I'm not going
to do it and and I would that would used
to be my identity rule number eight
swim forever you want to swim forever
adopt the mindset that you want to swim
forever most people if you're thinking
about swimming
you're swimming to reach the island
right if you're swimming out in the
ocean you're swimming to reach the
island
the island is is some gold the island is
I want to hit a million subscribers I
want a million in revenue or whatever
some arbitrary goal
the goal isn't to hit the island
your intention shouldn't be to hit the
island it should be the swim you have to
love swimming you want to swim forever I
want to swim forever
every now and then you might need to
look back
you know and see how far you've come
see how far you swam every now and then
we need that
that mindset that that that that
gratitude that perspective to say wow
I'm I'm so much further ahead Than I
Used to Be Right a big challenge with
Achievers is we don't feel like we've
done enough
so she's High Achievers you don't feel
like you've done enough
and and that can often be a drive
forward but sometimes it's so
overwhelming that it actually puts you
in a negative state where where it
prevents growth so in those moments you
look back and see how far you swam like
wow I've come a long way compared to who
I used to be the the accomplishments the
belief systems the mindset the
relationships like
the personal development how much have
you grown if you actually think about it
how much have you grown in the past five
years is probably crazy if you're a fan
of this channel you're watching this
video you've grown a lot in the past
five years and every now and then when
you're feeling low you need that
perspective shift to look back and see
how far you've come but otherwise it's
forward growth more growth you want to
swim forever you don't want to hit the
island you want to swim forever
we've all experienced those moments
where you you hit a goal
and then and then what what do you feel
you feel a moment of Happiness of of
accomplishment and then like oh is that
is that all there is
you know when I hit a million
subscribers on YouTube like that was a
drive that was the goal I want to hit a
million subscribers on YouTube
I wanted to hit it I don't even remember
what the goal I wanted to hit it before
Gary
I wanted to hit a million subscribers
before garyvee and we did it
and they're like oh I'm still the same
person
somehow we feel that when we
accomplish something we're going to feel
different we're going to be different
you're going to be a different person
when you hit that goal and it's it we
end up getting confused because it's not
even about the goal you become a
different person in the pursuit of the
goal
I've studied more successful people than
most people just the nature of the work
that I do and there's a reason why the
number one rule for Success over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again is you have to love what
you do you have to love the process
successful people they love the process
they love the doing they love the actual
showing up every day
I'm sitting here at a
Nina's inside there can we see Nina's
inside at a at a TNT it's a Chinese
grocery store she's inside doing
shopping I'm sitting here in the car
making videos why because I like it I
like I like the process I like it's not
about how many subscribers I have on the
channel I like feeling like this matters
that you I'm so grateful that you're
thank you honestly thank you for
watching this video I'm so grateful that
you're here watching this video that I
could make something from my car that's
worthy of somebody else's attention
thank you
I love this
we've done over 10 000 videos
why because I love it like if it's just
a strategy if you're just trying to
reach the island you drown
if you're just trying to reach the
island you drown you have to love
swimming
this is the mistake most entrepreneurs
make when they're first getting started
is you're just chasing an opportunity
but you don't actually love the process
this is a great
uh quote one of my favorite quotes of
all time it's an African saying that
beyond the mountain is more Mountains
and it's similar to the swimming analogy
what do you do when you get to the top
of the mountain there's another mountain
to climb you don't you don't ever want
to get to the top of the mountain think
about if you if you hit the top
you're gonna start to hate your life
because there's no growth because we
want more growth we want more learning
we want more progression
if you felt like you hit the top that's
the fast path down to depression beyond
the mountain is more Mountains the
greatest quote of all time at least one
of them I love that one I think a Ted
Turner's father whose goal was to be a
millionaire and then he hit the million
and
he killed himself
because he thought you know he wasn't
happy with his life he wasn't happy with
his his process he wasn't happy with
what we were doing every day but if he
hit a million dollars then everything's
gonna change then he's gonna be a
different person he hit his million
and he was the same person
he wasn't happy so he killed himself
so Ted Turner who's you know a
billionaire one of the wealthiest people
in the world decided I'm going to set a
goal so big that I'm not going to hit it
and that's the point of having a vision
you know a mission like something so big
Beyond yourself that you never hit it I
want to solve the world's biggest
problem that people don't believe in
themselves enough
I'm never gonna do that it's not it's
not gonna happen not in my lifetime and
yet I wake up every day trying to make
that happen in my lifetime
you have to want to swim forever rule
number nine
hold yourself accountable tell the
people around you
so Nina Nina stepped out but uh Nina my
son my team my family I'll let them know
hey if I say scary difficult or hard I
want you to let me know
if I say to you in any conversation I
can't because it's scary or it's
difficult or it's hard I need you to
call me out on it because I'm not gonna
I still don't catch all of them
it's a lot more than it used to be and
I'm probably I don't know 90 95 of the
way there but there'll still be some
small percentage and having people hold
you accountable
is really important
Now the default thinking for them is
going to be what are you talking about
you you're always doing all of these
things you're always showing up you're
always doing scary difficult hard in in
my case yeah but not like I could be
there's another level to this
and everything I want out of life my
mission my my vision my boldness is on
the other side my great life is on the
other side of even more scary difficult
than hard
I had to start living it
and so I need help in catching it
so you use yourself as as step one as
the first part but then if you can as a
bonus bring in the accountability to the
other people in your life who can help
you catch it and you're not allowed to
get angry at them you're not allowed to
get frustrated with them if if you say
one of your trigger words and they say
you just said it
you're going to want to say now but
she's this it doesn't count it doesn't
mean it uh I was thinking so stop
letting yourself off the hook
and said you say you're right I need to
go do the thing and the more you can
train that
trigger word came up I'm doing the thing
trigger war came up I'm doing the thing
trigger war came up another thing it's
scary I'm doing it it's difficult I'm
doing it's hard I'm doing it just
because you start shifting your identity
you start changing your self-talk
now you start to become the person that
you're proud of you start to become the
person that you you say you want to be
you start to actually become the person
you've become the best version of you
and rule number 10. before some very
special bonus Clips inflict pain inflict
so much pain on yourself a future regret
that if you don't do this thing how
painful it's going to be for you how
you're going to regret it your entire
life that it forces you into action to
do the thing that will make yourself
proud that will build the life you want
that will help create the dream that you
know you're capable of doing
actually look at your life and you enjoy
what you're doing
people ask me do I burn out in what I'm
doing like I don't I don't I don't burn
out I like I like it too much like this
making these videos I'm gonna go home
after this and
make more videos probably but this video
that I'm making for you right now is not
draining or depleting of my energy is
contributing to my energy I am
manufacturing energy by doing this
so that's why it's easy to do 10 000
more videos
because it gives me more than I give to
it
I get more energy as a result of doing
this I'm going to be a better
entrepreneur better husband a better
father a better boss a better teammate a
better Mentor as a result of making this
video
it gives me energy look at your work
that's how you avoid burnout if I was
doing things that that sap my energy if
I was in charge of like washing these
cars I'd be burnt out in in five hours I
would hate my life because I don't enjoy
washing cars I don't enjoy cars really
so look at your schedule do a nice audit
on your life how many of the activities
that you're doing every day are giving
you energy versus taking away energy how
many of the people that you're spending
time with are giving you energy versus
taking away energy
and you need to start shifting from I'm
just going to chase an opportunity I'm
going to do whatever it takes you
if you don't like it but if you don't
love it you won't do whatever it takes
because you don't love it and that's
okay stop judging yourself for not
working hard enough just you're not lazy
something you don't want to work hard
you just don't like the thing that
you're doing this doesn't feel like work
to me
so it's getting honest with yourself
it's doing an audit it's looking at your
calendar are you generally excited about
the things you're about to do today and
tomorrow and if not then then we have to
start to shift out of them
right do the things that give you energy
instead of taken away when you
understand what your single most
important core value is everything else
becomes so much easier so for me it's
belief right belief is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that I make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that I make is about
belief it has to be every interaction I
have every Workshop every book every
meeting all of it has to be run through
the believe framework right the glasses
I believe if I'm hiring somebody onto my
team skills alone aren't enough it's
great that you can write copies do you
believe in entrepreneurs it's a big
difference so when you understand your
core value everything else becomes
clearer and you're less likely to follow
what other people want you to do
everybody around you they have a goal
for you even if it's well intentioned
they have opinions on what you should do
with your life everybody around you this
is what you should do with your life
everybody has an opinion you don't know
which way to go if you don't know which
way to go it's because you don't know
what you stand for because you're
standing on quicksand but when you
understand your one word you're who your
most important core value it's like
you're standing on a rock that nobody
can push you from so how do you figure
that out quickly right I mean this is
200 something Pages let's boil it down
super quick for you you want to think
about all the people that you love your
favorite teacher what you loved about
your parents think about your favorite
musician your favorite band your
favorite song your favorite movie your
favorite book all your favorite things
the thing that when you are around
consuming it reading it being with them
it makes you feel bold alive amazing
confident Unstoppable right we've all
had those moments it's just not
consistent enough yet we're gonna make
it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three keywords that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love Mr Jones it's not because he taught
you grade four math right there was
something else about Mr Jones that you
love why do I love Seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things and they all come together it's
believe right my parents taught me that
I'm Evan can surely Karma because I can
do anything that I believe that I can
right and so through all the things that
I love believe is the common thread what
is it for you you have to figure it out
you have to figure it out it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down all of the people and the
things that you love three keywords for
each like do this this is important just
do it today it'll make a huge difference
in your life it's worth it this is the
best 15 minutes you can spend in your
life do it pause the video and do it and
then just see what comes up consistently
what word comes up over and over and
over and over and over and over again
chances are that's your one word that's
your who then when you discover it you
have to start living that life the
reason MO most people don't win isn't
because you don't have great ideas
you're a genius the only thing missing
is momentum you're dreaming huge that's
amazing I love it but there is zero
momentum it's never gonna be the right
time and nobody is coming to save you
the time is now to make your dreams
happen so here's a really fun example
yesterday I needed to take a break from
my work to go to the bathroom so I go to
the bathroom open up my Feedly and start
looking at you know some of the new
stories that were happening and there
was this amazing video that I saw about
a busker in Toronto who a company
organized what they call the cash mob
instead of a flash mob where they would
all show up at this guy doing his you
know guitar singing playing and just
throw money at him not at him but in the
guitar case right and they were they
probably made like a thousand bucks
they're throwing 20s and 50s Not Just
pennies and in you know dollar bills and
stuff but give him tons of money and and
it and he's starting to get overwhelmed
he's playing the guitar he's getting
over around and and I'm I'm getting
motivated and excited and just heartfelt
what a great moment and I decide in that
moment we need to make this video more
public we need to spread it this has to
go up on the channel I need to spread
awareness I want to I want to promote
this company who put this together I
love it what a great idea
and so right away like here's the thing
you get a great idea trust your great
ideas go do something about it I could
have easily filed that away next week
I'll work on it and then what guess
what's going to happen next week I'm not
going to work on it because I'm going to
move on to something else right I'm in
the middle of my day I've got priorities
and a plan for that day and then this
thing pops up I trust that idea trust
that it's great and that I gotta do
something about it because if I'm
inspired if you're inspired you're going
to create gold you're going to create
Magic
if you're not inspired then just keep
doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about I think you need to follow
that through and so I I parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and I made the ending and I
made the thumbnail and I made the
description and I made the title and I
created it all in one shot and I sent it
off to my editor Christina we love you
Christina say hey we got to put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took I don't know half an
hour
it took half an hour out of my day that
I was supposed to do other stuff to make
that happen because momentum matters
momentum matters it's the most important
thing you're a genius the ideas that you
have are gold they're genius you're just
not doing enough with it success is the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal what I took away most from that
definition is the word Progressive you
want progress you want to learn you want
to keep growing what was once a
challenge for you is now simple and it's
very easy to fall into a routine that
once served you but is now limiting you
the day you stop progressing is the day
that you start to hate your life and it
can be sneaky it could sneak up on you
without you even noticing what happened
so I was trying to think of a personal
story to share with you about this and I
realize it's been more than 10 years
since I've actually felt that I felt
that I've stopped progressing that that
I started to hate what I was doing it's
been over 10 years it was it was
basically since I started on YouTube and
I'm going to share with you the the
hacks that I used so that you won't fall
into that rut but what happened for me
10 years ago was I built my website
right I sold my business I had success
of speaking around the world I started
building my website
and I built it into a giant platform we
had a hundred thousand plus pages of
content making money from advertising
and I just stopped liking the business
it started to feel like we're putting
out content we're putting out articles
just trying to make money putting out
articles that that
um I didn't always believe 100 in we had
a bunch of guest people writing content
right we had four or five thousand
authors for the website and not all of
their opinions or views or mindset or
voice
reflected my own and I just stopped
liking the business it was a successful
business making money building a team I
had eight people I think at that time
and I decided you know what I this isn't
this isn't I'm losing the love for this
I need to try new things and I started
making YouTube videos it was one
experiment I probably did a bunch of
different things but YouTube was one
experiment that I sucked at but I loved
and I kept coming back to and and it
taught me it taught me a lesson it
taught me that you need to explore this
is this is what I tell a lot of people
when they're entrepreneurs I had a woman
uh Melissa who joined me on an IG live
the other day and she's talking about
how she's got a real estate business
that's making her money but she wants to
be a speaker and the speaking business
is growing I can't support her fully yet
but the real estate business gives her a
lot of money she's like well I like
doing both
like well no you don't
right like in five years where do you
want to be you want to still be doing
real estate no no five years I don't
want to be doing that I want to be doing
the speaking thing great that's where
you need to start spending more of your
time it doesn't mean quit the job it
doesn't mean stop doing real estate or
stop doing the thing that you're just
okay with but while you still have one
foot in it you have to explore you have
to try you have to taste you got to see
what else you can do spend one day a
week two days a week depending on your
financial situation is my advice to her
spend one day or two days a week
focusing on the speaking business so
that in six months you could be out of
the real estate business and being
speaking full-time and then do anything
you love right if you just like it
that should be a warning sign to get out
not ASAP but you need to start exploring
but so many people end up hating the
things they're doing so many
entrepreneurs start a business they love
it it's challenging it's exciting it's
exhilarating and then they found that
they bought themselves a job and they
actually hate their business and then it
becomes too late to get out because you
can't find the person to sell it to or
you just have to walk away from it you
don't win a Nobel Prize by telling
yourself that you want to win a Nobel
Prize you win a Nobel Prize by having a
mission so big that it forces you to
become somebody new a stronger more bold
more resilient version of you if you
make success your goal you will most
likely miss it because you have the
wrong outcome in mind make impact your
goal make your mission your goal and
you'll end up having more success than
you ever thought possible I look at my
YouTube channel as an example and the
next goal would be to have 10 million
subscribers right I got my hundred
thousand plaque I got three of them
there I got my million plaque
the next goal is 10 million and there's
nothing wrong with having goals but the
problem is if I made 10 million the
thing like all I'm doing is chasing down
10 million subscribers it forces you to
do short-term decisions that end up not
serving you right if I wanted to just
blow up my channel the best way to do it
isn't actually to spread positive
content negativity spreads much faster
than positivity if I made a top 10 video
on why this person's soccer and
expressive about how this person's an
idiot or people fighting people can't
help but see that people that's why
people stop to see the car accident on
the highway right we don't reward the
good drivers you want to see the chaos
you want to see what caused the flame
there's a fight on a street corner
you've stopped to see what's going on
right we're attracted to the negativity
more than the positivity that's a faster
way to blow up my channel the problem is
I wouldn't feel good about it
I don't want to spread negativity I
don't want to spread conflict and Chaos
I don't want to spread pessimism I don't
want to spread uh despair I don't want
to spread ego I don't want to spread
negativity I just I don't want to do
that and so it would lead to me flaming
out before I ever hit the goal that's
the problem you can have this goal this
is what most people do you have some
goal here's my goal I'm going to do
whatever it takes to get to that goal
the problem is you won't do whatever it
takes because it's going to get too hard
you can only do things for so long that
you don't love before you quit and give
up and so there's nothing wrong with
having a goal but more important than
the goals of the mission I want to solve
the world's biggest problem is something
that's never going to happen never in my
lifetime it's never going to happen I
want people to believe in themselves
more it's never going to hit that
ultimate goal where everybody is Michael
Jordan at something it will never happen
and I wake up every day trying to do
that and so if you make a goal
tied to some outcome like getting 10
million subscribers on YouTube it's
going to force you down a path that
likely won't serve you so you leave with
a mission you leave with the impact and
success will follow the difference in
people is their standards the world is
full of people who started with less
than what you already have right now and
they're winning and too many people are
out there complaining complaining that
you don't have the money that you don't
have the time that you don't have the
experience that you don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but others have done it
with those very same circumstances as
you with worse circumstances than you
the difference is they have a higher
standard for themselves and today we're
going to raise yours one of the things
I'm most proud about for myself why do I
love Evan Carmichael it's because when I
say I'm gonna do something I do it
especially when it gets hard like it
doesn't count until it gets hard and I'm
doing it not just for other people I'm
I'm doing it and that's because I
promise you that I would show up I'm
doing it for myself because I said I was
going to do something and then I go off
and do it this is the foundation of
self-esteem of self-confidence of
self-love doing it when you say you're
gonna do it and so on Monday I usually
have a two-hour walking meeting with
Alex Alex helps around Toronto and salsa
he comes over Monday's my mentoring day
and we'll usually go for a two-hour walk
around the city and it's starting to get
cold you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold and so we bundle up and we
go for our two-hour walk while we while
we talk and while we meet I'm trying to
do walking meetings more just for my own
health and and just because just for the
challenge of it because it's easy to
start something like that in the spring
or in the summer it's really hard to do
it when it's in the winter and you live
in Toronto Canada and it's snowing and
cold right so this Monday Alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but just sick and Nina my wife super
caring said hey maybe you shouldn't go
for a walk outside and and my heart just
like come on no we have to I said I was
gonna do it right I have to I have to
for myself I have to go on the walk like
I'll go on the walk and leave Alex at my
place and and just film the meeting with
him uh but we came up with a different
solution which was I have a I live in a
condom we have a gym in my condo and we
went down to the condo gym and I walked
on the treadmill while he stood or sat
next to me for two hours because I said
that I was gonna do it how important is
that one two hour walk not much right in
itself not much am I gonna get healthy
from doing that one walk no am I gonna
lose weight by doing that one walk no
I'm gonna have so much more mental
Clarity by doing that one walk of course
not
but it's the whole game because you're
teaching yourself that you follow
through you're teaching yourself that
you have high standards you're teaching
yourself that when you say you're gonna
do something you follow through because
life is coming for you with a ton of
roadblocks life is going to throw tons
of curve balls at you if you can only do
the thing that you said you were gonna
do when it's easy and the path is
perfectly clear you're never gonna do it
this is why people don't stay consistent
because as soon as life gets hard you
let yourself off the hook you allow your
standards to drop to say oh it's okay
yeah of course I can't go for a while
because Alex is sick
right and there are definitely
legitimate times when you should let
yourself off the hook if I was dying in
bed with the fever and I couldn't get
out of bed I wouldn't go for the walk
that makes sense don't be stupid there's
times where you need to be gentle on
yourself but more often than not we are
too gentle in ourselves when we
shouldn't be I could have done the walk
and we did it we did it in the in the in
the gym downstairs and Alex stood next
to me and sat next to me and didn't have
to go outside and and get the cold on
him and I still got my walk-in right and
I feel great about it
because I did it when it was hard
because here's this obstacle that life's
throwing at me here's an easy way when
everybody around me is saying you don't
have to go off and do it and a little
tiny voice inside my own head saying
okay well here's a chance you don't have
to do it like no be quiet voice I'm
doing it we're finding a solution let's
go and the solution isn't going to walk
on the treadmill downstairs what matters
is that you're productive that you get
results that you stop wasting time too
many people default to thinking that if
they just wake up an hour earlier
they're going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
going to be more productive in a 17-hour
day when you have less sleep so this is
a interesting message and timing for me
right now because I I love beating the
Sun up I love it I love working I like
it's my default state of Nina is off on
a Friday night with her friends or
something 80 chance I'm working I love
it I look forward to it when I go close
my eyes I can't wait for it to be the
next day like I'm pumped to go off and
do the work
I recently did a sleep study and my
doctor was concerned I wasn't getting
enough quality sleep so I went to go do
a sleep study and the doctor after going
through the results told me that I need
to be sleeping eight and a half hours to
nine hours a night
and it and it like
[Music]
super disappointed me eight and a half
hours to nine hours are you kidding me I
I'm trying to go from I was trying to go
from eight to seven I was waking up
after eight hours sleep and and feeling
still a little bit tired and so that's
why my doctor recommended even going to
the sleep study and I'm trying to figure
out how do I hack it to get down to
seven and still be fully functional not
not be you know lazy and slow and not
have my cognition and uh yeah he said I
need to be sleeping eight and a half to
nine hours a night he said is that is
that normal like are you not worried
like no as long as you're under 10 it's
normal people range from six to ten and
they're totally fine like this sucks I
mean I'm not happy about it I'm still
looking at how can I hack my sleep more
and we've tried a lot I have the chili
pad we've got you know meditation before
sleeping I'm lying on the bed of nails
with the thing behind me the pillow the
nail pillow uh no you know phones or
computers x amount of time before going
to bed red light filters on everything
right red lights no lights at all in the
place right like just these real red
lights going around after Sunrise after
Sunset lots of it cool down the
temperature I don't know all of it don't
eat past eight o'clock no caffeine past
two o'clock all of it I'm doing all of
that stuff all of it right plus probably
a lot more stuff I've I've studied and
hacked away I still believe there's a
lot more hacking I still want to get it
from nine to seven but but if I'm at
nine and I need nine I think you should
get nine I'm at the point now where if I
wake up and the Sun is still uh not up I
stay in bed and and that's actually uh
boosting of confidence it's like okay so
I wake up and sun is hasn't come up yet
okay this is hard this is difficult it's
difficult for me to not get out of bed
I'm gonna stay in bed just because now
I'm I'm a I'm a weird duck so maybe this
works for you maybe it doesn't but I was
having a great conversation with Jeremy
who's on my team who I've invested in
his business he's helping companies
scale their YouTube channels and he was
going through the same thing where he
was feeling a little tired in the
afternoon he wanted to nap on some
afternoons and that's never been me so
dude you need to just try uh waking up
without an alarm
I mean normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something
um so just wake up without an alarm and
see how it goes and he ended up sleeping
for nine hours and hating hating himself
for doing it it's like dude maybe you
need nine hours like much more important
than that extra hour or two is what are
you doing during the day if if you're
losing energy during the day and you
want to nap every afternoon you're not
being productive like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win I think everybody should get a
sleep test I think it's a brutal
experience you don't you barely sleep
right when you're there you got to stuff
up your nose and a million sensors all
over you but to know how much sleep you
actually need and making sure that
you're productive during the time that
you are awake that's the most important
thing that you are productive during the
time that you're awake is way more
important than if you wake up before the
sun gets up if you are doing something
new you are going to get rejected if
you're doing something that you're not
good at yet you're going to get rejected
if you're doing something that goes
against the status quo you are going to
get rejected so you have two choices
live a life with zero growth and never
get rejected or chase your dream deal
with the rejection that comes and go
change the world I have rejection all
the time in my life from Little
rejections of making videos that don't
pop to bigger rejections of projects
that I care deeply about that just don't
fly and people don't accept at the
beginning I look I look at this built to
serve this is a great example built to
serve is my new book coming out if you
want to pre-order it in the description
there's a link go get it tons of bonuses
looking forward to it this book
I'm insanely proud of
I think it's life-changing I mean it
should be I think the work that you
create should be life-changing but I
poured so much into this and I think
people need to read it like I I
desperately think that this book will
change a lot of people's lives it could
change your life I believe it's not just
hyperbole like I I truly fundamentally
believe him when I came up with the idea
I was on my tour earlier this year and I
did not have time to write it right I
was on my tour I'm behind on everything
a million things being thrown at me
meeting people doing my events seeing
the cities and it just I just decided I
had to write this book because of all
the feedback I was getting from people
it was all the one-on-ones I was doing
people the same questions kept coming up
how do I find my purpose how do I know
who I am how do I turn into a business
and so that's the that's the point of
the book figuring out what your purpose
is and how to use that to then serve the
world right it's called built to serve
and make it into a business so you can
make money doing it and build a team and
go off and live your mission when I
first pitched my publisher on it they
didn't want it they didn't want my book
right so uh your one word is down here
that's with penguin random house and
penguin passed so they had first my
first deal with uh penguin Random House
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book so as soon as I get my next
book they get the right to look at it
first before I give it to anybody else
right so that's why I signed it's like
okay here we go let's go it's a perfect
fit I mean it follows really nicely with
your one word
let's go right and they said uh no we're
gonna pass like
what how do you PR this is better than
your one word I mean I love your one was
great
this is this is the whole thing how do
you pass on this
um it's just and we had to wait because
it's 30 days and all these anyway legal
stuff
um so then we started looking at other
companies we started looking at other
publishing houses and there were other
ones that seemed to line up really well
with the content that they had the the
the author lineup that they have and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right uh said no
and I mean like I gotta I got a big
YouTube channel we have momentum we
already have our first book where like
why why and all sorts of different
reasons you know
um just not not doing personal
development books anymore not whatever
uh nobody came out and said like we hate
you Evan so maybe hopefully that's not
the reason
um and then we found one that that
picked it up I was like okay
let's go and if if that one didn't pick
it up then then we would have kept
looking for more Publishers or I would
have just made it myself
just self-publishing put it out right
what do you do when the people around
you don't accept what you have when you
want to take something in a New
Direction I could have done something
else I could have done something easier
if I just did a book about Jack ma right
in his room for Success that would be
easier to pick up than this which I talk
about on the channel but it's not the
main thesis of the channel but that's
what I want to make and that's what I'm
going to make whether it's I get a
publisher or we're gonna you know create
it myself it's gonna be birthed into
existence because I decided so and just
taking that mindset and approach you
have to if you love the thing if you're
doing something different
then you have to keep going when people
say that I don't want to pick it up that
it sucks that it's stupid that you're
maybe it's even a great idea but you're
not the person who's gonna do it right
you have to keep going I think judging
yourself is actually great I think you
need it I think it's healthy I think
people should be harder on themselves
the problem is people can't handle being
even a little bit harder on themselves
because they're already at the point of
being depressed or even suicidal the
secret starts with self-love your
self-love has to equal your
self-criticism you have to be your
biggest fan as well as your biggest
critic the root problem isn't judging
yourself it's not loving yourself one of
the challenges to think of being human
is we are social animals we're social
creatures we rely on each other we need
each other we want to belong we want to
be part of tribes we want to do things
together right we want to be around
other people
so that makes us want to fit in and that
makes us play small worry about what
people think about us because if we
don't do the thing that they want us to
do they might judge us and kick us out
of the tribe the good news is there's so
many different tribes you can do now
right there's so many different people
that it may not be your friends that you
have right now may not be your parents
or your family or your community right
now but whatever you want to do there is
a group of people who believe the same
things you believe we think the same way
you think and I think one of the
healthiest things you can do is whenever
you feel the eyes of potential judgment
for something that you want to do you
have to go up and do it just to show
yourself comparison to other people I
think is actually a good thing
as most people look at other people
start feeling insecure and then kick
themselves down the key is to kick
yourself forward not down but you need
that kick otherwise you stay where you
are this is one of the reasons why I
love modern success why I created all my
YouTube channels and all the content
that I've done and I have the people
behind me on the wall because I love
looking at other people I love learning
from other people I love seeing somebody
do amazing things and say that's what's
possible this is what's possible I look
at Les Brown as an example and I think
he's the greatest speaker of all time at
least that I've I've seen I don't maybe
maybe the ancient Greeks were better I
don't know but but Les Brown modern era
on video I think is the greatest speaker
and
I look at that and say that's what's
possible not that I can't do that here's
what most people do they look at Les
Brown and say well I can't do that
and then you start feeling insecure and
I'm just I'm just an imposter trying to
be like that now and then they quit
and then they feel they feel low with
self-esteem when they and they beat
themselves up over because they're not
less brown
I look at last Friday that's what's
possible this is what this is what
humans can actually accomplish and
Achieve I want some of that I want to
get better I want to drive and improve
not to be the next less brown but be the
best me but this is what's possible I
look at David Goggins Man David Goggins
look he came out of nowhere who was
David Goggins did you guys know David
Goggins five years ago no he blew up out
of nowhere because of the passion and
intensity and truth of his message right
I love that and it's easy to say and
look at that say well look at how
passionate David Goggins is and look how
he blew up I could never do that
I'm not as strong as him I'm not as
crazy as him I don't have the same
mindset as him and so I can't do that
and you compare yourself to Goggins and
then you say well I can't I can't and so
you don't start that's the problem
you should look at Goggins and say look
at what's possible you could come from
nowhere nobody knowing who you are and
in a short amount of time blow up
because you have a message that matters
you can look at how passionate he is
about his message every video he's got
insane passion right this guy he's not
going to give you nice hugs and
compliments but he he cares about his
message right you can see that and you
could take that as what's possible you
can you can care deeply about your
message too and model David Goggins and
and apply that to make your message
stronger and better I think if you just
were competing with yourself I think
you're actually gonna suck
I think I think if you're the best at
something and you don't have any
competition I think you actually suck uh
being the big fish in a small pond
actually limits a lot of creativity uh
limits your ability to go off and Crush
things I think I think it is I think
when you even even in animals when you
see animals going up against each other
in a race
when when somebody's close you work a
little bit harder right I think I think
we need that in our ecosystem the key
though again is to make sure you're
kicking yourself forward to say this is
what is possible not this person so much
better than me I suck feeling insecure
feeling depressed you need the kick just
make sure you're kicking yourself
forward not down it may not be your
fault but it's your responsibility it's
not your fault that you were born broke
but it's your responsibility to fix it
it's not your fault that you had no
education but it's your responsibility
to learn it it's not your fault that you
had no connections but it's your
responsibility to make them it may not
be your fault but it's your
responsibility and the sooner you accept
that the sooner you're gonna win so I
recently posted to my YouTube Community
tab a quote about momentum I think
people don't have momentum and I think
the path to get momentum is to do work
for free for ideal clients until you can
prove your value and then they pay you
so here's what I wrote I wrote If you
have no momentum no traction no clients
and start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can can't wait to have again and pay for
this time hashtag believe and every time
I write this always sends a great
positive feedback but but this time
somebody wrote a kind of negative
comment and so I wanted to read it
because it's highly applicable in this
video he said Kitsch I don't know about
some of your advice everything is my
fault and work for free to which I reply
yes when you Embrace those two you'll
start crushing your goals it's a hard
message to to take on right whether
everything is your fault everything is
your responsibility where you are right
now it's not about beating yourself up
it's not about saying I suck and I can't
get out it's saying listen this is what
happened to me that's the past the past
doesn't have to equal to the Future
everything that I was born into and and
the circumstances that I grew up with
they don't have to be where I go going
forward look at all your Heroes look at
the people who made huge inroads change
the world the people that you look up to
and aspire to be like very few of them
were born super wealthy most of them had
a worse upbringing than you did and they
could make it so why can't you you're
just locked in your story too many
people are locked into their story
they're not taking responsibility
they're not saying this is my my problem
to get out of
I wasn't put here right you've been
drafted into a war that you did not
start you were put here
and you have to survive and then you
have to learn to thrive and it's that
decision that you are in charge that
you're responsible that if you go to the
mirror and you say why am I not
achieving my goals why am I not further
ahead as long as you're blaming somebody
else that might keep you comfortable
keeps you comfortable it means you don't
have to do anything right you're not
winning because your mom you know hit
you you're not winning because your dad
never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting and everybody else
around us are doing the same thing
nobody's taking accountability
everybody's saying it's somebody else's
fault right of course it's not your
fault that you're losing because then
you have to do something about it and
even if you're not losing you're not
hitting the goals as hard as you should
and it's so much easier to put the blame
on somebody else and say well
it's that person's fault or really it's
a person in the mirror it's you it's me
I am not further ahead in my business on
my YouTube channel not because of the
YouTube algorithm
not because my team didn't deliver the
Right video on time me I'm the problem
it's my fault it's my responsibility
right I have to go fix it I created this
mess it's not a mess it's amazing but
I'm not a 10 million subscribers
because of me
it's not that people don't want to watch
the content and people don't want to be
inspired
it's me I need to get better I need to
improve and and even if it wasn't my
fault just taking that on
gives you hope that you can change it
and as soon as you start putting not
even the blame I think blame is not I
don't think blame helps I don't care
who's to who to blame I care how do we
fix it right if there's a problem that
happens in my business not like who
screwed up I don't care who screwed up I
care what are we gonna do to make sure
that we can get out of this hole and
then it doesn't happen again the next
time right taking personal
accountability for where you're at if
you have not hit your goals this is good
news you can
but nobody's coming to save you
nothing's gonna magically change around
you you you're the change you will make
the change you can go make it happen
if I want to grow my business bigger I
need to accept that I need to grow
bigger me personally Evan Carmichael I
is my fault is my responsibility I am to
blame
and use that as a kick forward to say
great like at the beginning that may
suck say oh man I've wasted how many you
know weeks months years going down the
wrong path just casting
blame on other people realizing now it's
my fault okay what can you do about it
now you can change it like at the start
the reality the realization sucks but
then it's also the greatest thing of all
time if you're coming out of
from under the Rock and realize oh my
God this is all my fault
that gives you the power to fix it
because as long as you're relying on
somebody else to do something and they
don't show up you can constantly blame
them but you're never growing you never
accomplish anything because you're
waiting for them you have to wait for
anybody
it's just you and you can fix it you
have the strength you have the power
you're Michael Jordan you have the
abilities you have the skill set and if
you don't have it yet you can develop it
you can acquire it because your Heroes
did it and you can too whatever you want
to learn you can learn public speaking
selling being a YouTuber anything if you
want to learn it there is nothing
stopping you except your story because
you tell yourself that you're too young
that you're too old it's too late you're
too broke you don't have the resources
you don't have the connections you don't
have the education you don't have the
right family there's always a story you
have not learned the skills that you
want and need because you've told
yourself that you can't and that's the
mindset shift that needs to change now
so I recently made a rap video on my
channel there's a Chinese song that I
became obsessed with for some reason I
was looking up Chinese music for my wife
I found this one song I loved it it got
stuck in my head and then for whatever
reason I'm lying in bed we go to bed
around 10 30 11 and lyrics just start
popping to my head I don't understand
what the Chinese songs about but lyrics
start popping to my head about a wrap so
as I come in I start writing it down I
try to go back to sleep more lyrics come
and write it down go back to sleep I
send myself emails because that's how I
get it out of my system
it gets to three something in the
morning 3 30 close to that and like you
know what I'm still getting these ideas
I'm just gonna get up and do it I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna get up and and rap
I'm gonna make this rap video I'm gonna
finish off the lyrics and then I'm gonna
spend my day making a rap video it's not
how I wanted to plan my day it was not
on my calendar I was supposed to be
sleeping but I'm gonna wake up and do
this rap
we put it all together uh did a whole
bunch of takes sent it to Christina to
help me edit it and then the next day
boom final version was up on the main
Channel now
I don't pretend to have amazing rap
skills right I think the lyrics for fire
I think the song is amazing I think I
think Christina did the best she could
with what I gave her and I think the rap
was pretty good I'm proud of myself I'm
I'm
for
amount of time how good a product I made
I'm emotional I'm I'm committed I'm
connected to the song and I'm yelling by
the end of the song now at the same time
people are leaving comments some people
love it and calling me you know Eminem
instead of Eminem some people are loving
it just because it's me and some people
are are nice saying you know what you're
not really a rapper but but good effort
way to put yourself out there
very kind very kind comments
be a great rapper
[Music]
I may not be top one percent rapper but
if I practice something I could be great
at it just like you
you could be a great rapper why can't
you be a great rapper I think the lyrics
are fire I practiced for one day and
made a video and that's what came out if
I practice every day making rap I could
crush it
just like making my YouTube videos I
sucked at the beginning I'm a better
rapper now than I was a YouTuber at the
very beginning of my career go back and
watch the first video I sucked I was shy
introverted you know scared of the
camera all of it
and so the audacity to believe that I
could be a rapper right it doesn't make
sense how does that make sense just
because I have Kanye West on my wall now
I can be a rapper right this is what
other people will tell us and is what
you'll tell yourself I can't be a rapper
but why not
you just don't believe in yourself
enough you can do it it's practice
get mentors practice put in the work you
can get great at anything it's a skill
it's just a skill
it's a skill that anybody can learn most
things are just a skill that anybody can
learn right to make a great cup of
coffee I suck at it but I could pick it
up I feel like I could pick it up it's a
skill anybody can learn there are very
few things very very few things there
are some things that require you know a
certain amount of athleticism but Spud
Webb could dunk you know there's a few
things right if you are 95 years old and
want to be a quarterback in the NFL
that's probably not going to happen but
we easily jump to those exceptions
meanwhile the thing that you need to
learn
that will help you get to where you want
to go that thing that skill set is
totally learnable there's no reason why
you can't do it there is no reason why
you can't do it so I believe I could be
a great rapper I may not win you know a
Grammy and may not win awards for it but
I could be a great rapper I could and so
can you you could be a great rapper you
could be a great entrepreneur you can be
a great YouTuber you can be a great
pianist you can be a great anything
it's a skill with practice and
repetition and love and execution and
dedication 6 000 attempts later
you can be great at it the single
greatest thing that you can do to
improve the quality of your life is to
take responsibility for it no more
blaming your parents or the country or
the government or your family or your
community or your education no more
blaming other people it's you it's you
it may not be your fault where you are
right now but it is your responsibility
alone to fix it you didn't pick where
you started but you can choose where you
end up it's up to you so I remember
growing up my parents were very hardcore
in education you see my parents behind
me here
I'm eight or nine here this is my
parents and we were a middle class
family we weren't poor by any stretch
but we also you know we're not rich and
my parents invested basically everything
they had into our education they put us
all in the private schools and taken
three kids into private schools was a
giant chunk of the income that they made
and so we didn't spend money on a lot of
other stuff you know I remember driving
into my school and all of my all of the
friends all the other people at the
school had all these fancy cars that
when they're when they turned 16 they're
you know given a Mercedes or BMW from
their family and you know my family had
a reliant cake car that kind of made a
bunch of noises that as I came into to
the school that was I don't know however
many years old just because my family
you know prioritized education and and
we were playing in a league that was
maybe above our means but they valued
that so much and then we took a hit on
other things and I remember used to get
made fun of for the car and I never went
on the vacations that they went on and I
didn't have the fancy watches and all
that other stuff and there was one
friend of mine
it was kind of in a similar boat where
his parents you know weren't making a
lot of money invested everything that
they had into his education too and so
we we quickly became friends as the uh
as I guess the poor kids at the school
but it's funny now because I never blame
my parents I I'm super grateful for the
opportunities I mean why I have them up
on my wall that they invested so much
and that they cared and
it's on me like if my business doesn't
work out it's not their fault
right up until you know you can
potentially move out I don't know what
age you want to say if it's 14 15 16 18
but after a certain age you're an adult
you have to take responsibility for your
life the only thing missing in your life
is momentum you're a genius you've got
great ideas you are the Michael Jordan
of something the only thing that is
stopping you is your ability to do
difficult things and start building
momentum I think for so many people it's
not just doing the thing that scares you
first first thing in the morning it's
doing it at all most people just don't
do it at all you've got a great idea you
know it can work but you're afraid of
judgment you don't know where to start
you're afraid of it being not perfect
and people telling you that you suck and
you failing publicly you're afraid of
all that stuff and so you don't do
anything you got your foot on the gas
and brake at the same time knowing that
you're capable of more knowing that you
have greatness in here but then being
too afraid to go off and execute it and
so I think not just starting your day
with the thing that scares you it's just
moving doing something anything just
getting started on your crazy idea it's
not that you're leaving it to the
afternoon it's that most people aren't
doing it at all so I was on a call with
an entrepreneur friend of mine yesterday
and she was upset she was frustrated she
had decided last year mid last year
right June July last year that she
needed to let somebody go on her team
this person was being toxic in their
environment was still producing results
for the company but just being a big
drag on the company on the culture and
on herself as trying to lead this team
of people and so she decided I gotta let
this person go it's six seven months
later now and she still hasn't done it
she still hasn't done it because she's
afraid of maybe not finding the right
person to replace the impact of having
to go through training and hiring all
over again and she just hasn't made the
decision the biggest problem is she has
not decided and so I said
when is this gonna matter to you you
decided you've decided right last year
six seven eight months ago and you still
haven't done the thing and she said well
if it gets to a year and I still haven't
done it then I have to go up and do it
and this is where your standards come
into place
how long after you've made a decision do
you actually start to do something about
it in her case her standards were a year
in that she decided but then a year
later that's when that's when it's too
much that's when it's gone too far that
she hasn't done it in a year now it's
too much I want you to shorten that Gap
teach yourself that as soon as you
decide you do something you act you put
the plan into motion because you don't
have that many years left I look at her
you know she's she's not old yet she's
not midlife yet but you don't have that
many years left
and this isn't even that big a decision
whatever is in front of you is not
actually that big a decision there are
much bigger decisions I had it may feel
like a big decision it may feel like it
but after you've done it and you get
through it you realize huh I could do
that again and there's another bigger
decision in the head you need to shorten
the gap between deciding that you want
to do something and actually taking
action towards it who you spend time
with is who you become it's why I
created this channel so you and I can
hang out with people like Warren Buffett
you may never meet Warren Buffett but
you can learn from him you can be
inspired by him and you can change your
life for the better by consuming this
kind of content I love violent success
because I learned from Bill Gates Bill
Gates was the first guy that I modeled
success from I had a software company
was struggling was making no money I
told my partner I quit and then I asked
myself somebody has done this before I
can't be the first person to try to
build a software company it can't be
this hard please somebody's figured this
out and the only person who came to my
mind was Bill Gates who started
Microsoft I hadn't been really that
interested in Reading I hadn't been that
interested in starting success I was
just trying to come up with ideas myself
and I was desperate right I told my
partner I quit I was desperate I was at
rock bottom and so I said Somebody's
figure this out I can only think of Bill
Gates at Microsoft and so I studied his
company and how he started the zero to
one right how did he make his first
million what did he do and it was
through Partnerships and I applied that
strategy to my business and shortly I
have to have my first deal for thirteen
and a half thousand dollars and I felt
like I won the lottery and after that I
had a pattern to use over and over and
over again and since then it's been 20
years now of sharing that with you guys
it's been for me constant learning it's
the name of my channel modeling success
it's why I have all these people behind
me on the wall that's why I make these
videos every day it's why I love
learning from people like Warren Buffett
and Steve Jobs and Kanye and Oprah and
all these people because they can shift
you because they shifted me and the
thing that they give you at least for me
they give me one the inspiration the
motivation the idea that look at what
they started with if they could start
from there and end up at this new place
why can't I you you already have more
resources and Bill Gates did when he
started you have more resources than
Kanye did than Steve Jobs did when they
started you're in a better position than
they were they would have to create
amazing things go study Oprah's story
and tell me that you're in a worse
position than Oprah was when she started
you're not you're not and so it's
inspiration the other part is tactics
ideas specific strategies right Bill
Gates doing Partnerships through
distributorships all of these things
learning from that and saying hey I can
apply that to my business maybe not 100
but it gets you eighty percent of the
way and instead of you figuring out the
entire solution you just have to figure
out how to bridge that 20 Gap at the end
it's much easier it can link to your
success
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there you are what you consistently do
the problem for people watching this
video for you your problem is that you
know where you want to go you know what
you want to accomplish you actually even
know the habits that you need to do